daily wire has this report fast food
restaurant chain Chick-fil-A received
backlash on social media as
conservatives learned that the firm's
corporate office advances a number of
diversity initiatives a revelation which
came as Brands such as Bud Light and
Target face criticism for embracing woke
ideology social media users noted that
Chick-fil-A which is a long-standing
reputation as a firm run on the basis of
conservative and Christian principles
hired Eric Reynolds as vice president of
diversity equity and inclusion two years
ago
Chick-fil-A prominently features a
number of diversity programs meant only
for females and members of racial
minorities on a Dei segment of its
website which surfaced in the days after
Target about light witness sales and
market capitalization hits
Beyond collaborations with various
National diverse professional
development organizations such as the
women's Food Service forums the national
black MBA Association and the
association of Latino Professionals of
America the restaurant chain offers
Community groups such as women in
business the black employee research
Resource Group and the Chick-fil-A Green
Team the company also seeks to develop
quote mentorship development and
partnership opportunities for
minority-owned businesses to
strategically engage with their supply
chain
Chick-fil-A additionally includes sexual
orientation gender identity and gender
expression in its employment
non-discrimination statement alongside
race sex religion and Veteran status
now uh first of all as others have
pointed out this is no surprise from
Chick-fil-A
uh they didn't go woke
just now
if there was if there was a specific
moment when they went woke or at least
when it became apparent to the public
that they went woke that was back and I
think this was in 2020
when Dan Cathy the CEO of the company a
couple years ago on stage at some kind
of event
um got on his knees and Shine the shoes
of a black man on stage as a show of of
racial submission so it was another
struggle session
ritual humiliation that he willingly
engaged in
this was the CEO of Chick-fil-A so after
this moment if you still had any notion
that Chick-fil-A wasn't woke well I
don't know where you got that idea from
let's go back and watch that again here
it is so I I invite folks just to put
some words to action here and if we need
to find somebody that needs to have this
shoe shine we need to just go right on
over and shine their shoes
and uh whether they got tennis shoes or
own or not maybe they got sandals on it
really doesn't matter
but there's a time in which we need to
have you know some some personal
action here maybe we need to give them a
hug too brother that's some and some
some stocking Chick-fil-A
but uh I bought about 1500 of these and
I gave it all our Chick-fil-A operators
and staff a number of years ago and uh
so any expressions of a contrite heart
of a sense of humility a sense of Shame
a sense of embarrassment uh began with
an apologetic heart
yeah well certainly you get
embarrassment out of that
um so if he has a sense of embarrassment
if you have a sense of embarrassment
while bending down to shine a black
man's shoes uh as a show of of you know
white guilt the sense of embarrassment
is not from the fact that you're white
it's from it's from what you are doing
you are embarrassing yourself and did I
hear that right because I've seen that
clip before I think I
maybe I never watched that clip all the
way to the end because it's unbearable
although I just made you I made you bear
it just now
um
but did he say at the end there that he
gave shoe shining kits to his employees
in case they come across any black
people whose shoes they want to shine
did I did I get that right I think I did
uh
so yes Chick-fil-A is woke
and even putting aside the pathetic
display that we just watched there
um
the diversity equity and inclusion stuff
is always left-wing indoctrination it's
always woke
in the not too distant past private
citizens used to be largely that private
well what's changed the internet has
changed think about everything you've
searched for watched or tweeted on the
internet now imagine all that data being
crawled through collected aggregated by
Third parties into permanent public
records to keep my data private when I
go online I use expressvpn there are
hundreds of data Brokers out there whose
sole business involves buying and
selling your data they don't even have
to tell you who they're selling it to or
get your consent one of those data
points is your IP address data
Harvesters use your IP to uniquely
identify you and your physical location
but you can mask your IP address with
expressvpn expressvpn reroutes my
connection through an encrypted server
that makes it more difficult for third
parties to find me sounds complicated
but really you just have to open the app
and tap one button on whatever device
you're using it really is that simple if
like me you believe that your data is
your business secure yourself with the
number one rated VPN on the market use
my Link at expressvpn.com Matt walshow
to get three extra months for free
that's exp
resvpn.com Matt Walsh show
and I've heard some people say that hey
just because they have a Dei initiative
doesn't automatically mean they're cow
Towing to the left
yes it does
that's what these initiatives are
like there's no such thing as a Dei
initiative that is uh conservative or is
neutral
it is all born from left-wing ideology
all of it
and and and automatically
if it's a diversity equity and inclusion
program
um they mean diversity equity and
inclusion in the way that the left means
it
that's automatically how it's meant
like there there are
there can be a context where you can use
the word diversity and it's not a bad
thing or a left-wing thing
um
right but if it's in this context then
the left owns that
and so it they mean diversity in the way
that the left means it
and how does the left mean it they mean
it exactly in the way that we just saw
there from Dan Cathy
which is anti-white white people
debasing themselves white people are
guilty white people have to apologize
fingers pointed at white people it's all
your fault that's how that's what they
mean
that's what diversity we talked about
this last week that's what diversity
always means diversity means anti-white
when it's coming from the left
if Chick-fil-A has diversity initiatives
that means it's an anti-white initiative
and that's why they're well they have
programs to help minority-owned
businesses what about what are
women-owned businesses what so white
males don't they don't need your help
it really it's it's horrific
it's wrong it's evil
it is evil to go out as a as a you know
a wealthy Corporation and say we're
going to help all the women and minority
owned businesses
you know there are a lot of white males
out there who own businesses and they're
serving their communities and they're
struggling
and they could really use the help too
so to skip over somebody because they're
a white male is disgusting it's awful
we should condemn it
for the same reason everybody would
condemn it if it was a diversity
initiative where we're going to help all
the business owners except for black
women
can you even imagine that can you
imagine any sort of initiative any kind
of uh program
that any Corporation or any government
entity endorsed
well we're going to go out and we're
going to find business owners uh and
we're going to help all the business
owners except if you're a black woman
we're not going to help you
and it wouldn't it would then everybody
would say Well that's that's incredibly
racist and sexist
and you know the it wouldn't do any good
to say well no it's not it's not nothing
against the black women what do you mean
you're specifically excluding them of
course it's something against them
well no I mean just because we have a
program to help everybody except this
one group that we've singled out doesn't
mean same thing nothing personal against
them well then why aren't you helping
them
why not have a program to just help
everybody why not help any business
owner
here's a crazy idea what about looking
at the actual businesses themselves and
making your judgment based on that
you know finding the businesses that are
especially struggling finding the ones
that are especially important to their
communities whatever
foreign
it's not just left wing it is far left
it is gross and disgusting and we should
condemn it and I don't want to hear from
it there have been some conservatives
even ones that I respect who have said
well look we don't want to you know we
don't want to um the perfect is the
enemy of the good and all that and
Chick-fil-A is generally on our side so
let's not go after them yeah they have a
Dei initiative but who cares yeah
they're they're you know doing programs
to help everybody except for white men
they're singling white men white men get
on your knees and Shine the shoes of a
black man we're not going to help you
yeah they're doing all that but
otherwise they're good
no I mean it's a it's a tired slogan at
this point but it is true to say
um this is why we lose it's because of
that kind of attitude we got to stop
making exceptions we have to stop
extending Grace to these people that
will never extend it back to us
like call things what they are
and uh and let's just be and have zero
tolerance okay a zero tolerance policy
as conservatives we should have a zero
tolerance policy for any Dei any
diversity initiative anything anti-white
anything that pushes
um that that that that pushes the trans
agenda
Pride flags all of that is far left
extremism
it is harmful it is poisonous to society
all of it and we should have zero
tolerance for all of it
that's the only way it is the only way
because the other way we've tried
so if you're one of the people that says
well let's you know let's uh we don't
have to throw it all out let's try to be
a little bit more you know
um find a middle ground if you're one of
those people you are representing the
Viewpoint it's not a new idea this is
this that has been the strategy
up until now
has it worked
it's worked for the left
hasn't worked well for us
we only started making real progress in
the culture as conservatives when we
drew a hard line
okay not a line in the sand a line in
the cement that is not going to move
we started drawing the hard lines
that's when we started making progress
when we started when we started to look
at entire categories of things and said
all of that is wrong we don't want any
of it we have no tolerance for it get
rid of all of it
okay the transiting of kids
finally the right draws a hard line and
says all of that is terrible I don't
want any of it don't bring the trans
stuff around kids period none of it
don't put it on a baby onesie don't put
it on uh you know don't don't put it in
the in the in the front of your store so
kids can see it don't put it in the
schools don't put it in the textbooks
and when we said that we finally started
making progress but only then
it's the same thing with all this LGBT
Pride stuff
and the Dei stuff
there is no way to like well we'll tell
you we want little little pieces of it
are okay you know and then we'll get rid
of the bad side the only way is is push
all of it aside
make all of it toxic
and punish
punish the people who promote it and
engage in it that's the only way
hey YouTube thanks for listening to the
show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there